as you all know i am nothing if not a
sunny cheerful optimist i prefer to
believe that we live in a world of
rainbows and gumdrops that's just how i
like to see the world and that's why
when i encounter abject lunacy and
absurdity i still sometimes have a hard
time believing
believing it you know believing that
it's true there's a part of me that
clings to the hope the desperate dying
hope that the dumbest most incorrigibly
stupid things are really just a joke a
dark kind of satire and yet those hopes
are almost always
in the end dashed that brings us to the
events of yesterday afternoon but before
we get there we gotta back up a little
bit the day the day before yesterday
when the podcast movement conference
kicked off in dallas this is a trade
expo for podcasters organized and run by
a group called podcast movement
podcasters from around the country they
come together and they they talk about
podcasting now frankly as a podcaster
myself
the event sounds like a nightmare like
the last thing i'd ever want to do is be
around a bunch of other podcasters
talking about podcasting that's just me
you know the daily wire had a more
positive attitude about it and so
the company sent set up a booth on the
convention floor to be clear we paid to
set up a booth the money was accepted by
this group podcast movement and uh the
booth was set up and everything seemed
to be fine
until tragedy struck
ben shapiro showed up at the conference
now he wasn't speaking there he wasn't
presenting anything he just kind of
showed up
and uh said hello to people took some
pictures with fans and then he left
as far as i know he didn't lash out
violently at any point he didn't go
berserk and start murdering podcasters
left and right and even if he did you
know there are so many podcasters in the
world that honestly it wouldn't be that
big of a deal we have enough to spare
but that's not what happened he also did
not despite reports of the contrary uh
bite the head off of a kitten while
uttering demonic incantations he didn't
even drink blood or breathe fire he did
none of those things so far as i'm aware
and yet podcast movement the next day
issued this tweet which when i saw it
for the first time i could only stare at
it blankly for several minutes trying to
convince myself that it's supposed to be
satirical but alas it is not they
tweeted
hi folks we owe you an apology before
before sessions kick off for the day
yesterday afternoon ben shapiro briefly
visited the pm 22 expo area near the
daily wire booth
though he was not registered or expected
we take full responsibility for the harm
done by his presence
there's no way around it we agreed to
sell the daily wire a first booth based
on the company's large presence in
podcasting the weight of that decision
is now painfully clear
shapiro is a co-founder a drop in
however unlikely should have been
considered a possibility
oh but they aren't done yet it continues
those of you who call this unacceptable
are right in nine wonderful years
growing and celebrating this medium pm
has made mistakes
the pain caused by this one will always
stick with us we promise that sponsors
will be more carefully considered moving
forward just to clarify no twtdw
representatives were scheduled to appear
on panels and shapiro remained in the
common space and did not have a badge if
you have questions we're here to talk
thank you for reading and we hope you
continue to join us from here on out
now in fairness i will admit that ben's
presence in the office causes uh me pain
and trauma as well but that's only
because he stole my giant stuffed walrus
if any of the people at the podcast
conference even have giant stuffed
walruses theirs were home safe and not
threatened by ben shapiro at all so what
was their complaint
well a short time after these tweets
from the podcast movement went out the
daily wire released video from ben's
brief time at the conference so you can
watch for yourself
and decide
whether this reaction from the people
there was warranted so here's the
footage and of course you know
it goes without saying viewer discretion
is advised here it is
yesterday afternoon ben shapiro briefly
visited the pm 22 expo though he was not
registered or expected we take full
responsibility for the harm done by his
presence
so do i get to get a picture
all right
[Music]
thank you we agreed to sell the daily
wire a first-time booth based on the
company's large presence in podcasting
the weight of that decision is now
painfully clear
[Music]
during event planning the dangerous
nature of the company's messaging was
overlooked
[Music]
those of you who called this
unacceptable are right podcast movement
has made mistakes the pain caused by
this one will always stick with us
yeah thanks for everything you do thank
you so much
[Music]
my god
he's a monster
those people
certainly look like they were fearing
for their lives because that's what you
do when you're deathly afraid of
somebody you ask for a selfie
um
may seem to be sort of an unorthodox
strategy but it turned out to be an
effective defense mechanism perhaps it's
a tactic you could try the next time
you're being chased through the woods by
an axe murderer you can stop them from
killing you by just asking them to pose
for a picture
now in any event uh clearly not
everybody was happy to see ben there uh
one podcaster who goes by the handle
starplanes on twitter
took a picture of ben from a safe
distance and tweeted it with a caption
hey podcast movement what the f
continuing it says as a trans a queer
person as someone with a uterus this
does not make me feel welcome this does
not make me feel safe
a short time later star planes provided
this update just confirm with the pod
move team that they did not know shapiro
was attending in fact they were told he
was not him showing up was the first
they knew about it does that make
everything okay no am i much happier
knowing he was not an invited guest
absolutely
now you might be asking yourself who
gives a damn what starplanes thinks why
is she special was benchmark supposed to
get special clearance from her
specifically before simply existing
within a 100 foot radius of her
well yes that's exactly what was
supposed to happen apparently
and that's why due to this complaint
from star planes and maybe a few other
complaints though that's the only one
i've actually seen
the organization issued what may go down
in history as the most pathetic apology
of all time
it certainly wins the title for this
month at least i think we can agree on
that
now what makes this all the more
pathetic and embarrassing
is that ben shapiro is one of the very
top podcasters in the business the daily
wire as a company is one of the top
podcast publishers according to the
latest ranking from podrak we're the
sixth largest publisher
in the country with 72 million downloads
just last last month alone
which means we beat companies like
disney and fox and paramount and cumulus
in fact our performance is even more
impressive than that as as uh podrak
counts us as having 12 active shows
iheartradio which is the number one
publisher
has 678 active shows
wondering at number two has 202
npr at 3 has 46. so we come in at number
six with only 12.
and less than half of those 12 are daily
shows so pound for pound in terms of the
average number of downloads per show we
actually should be number two right by
the new york times the point here is
that
if you're a podcaster
attending a podcasting convention with
podcasting talks and workshops
you should want us there you should be
coming up to us
for podcasting classes you should be
asking us to teach our secrets if you
see ben shapiro walking around you
should be coming to him for advice not
running away in fear with your hands
over your ears
star planes whose real name apparently
is talmud here
is in the podcasting business and yet
nobody's ever heard of this person
she's had no success
her career has been pitiful no offense
but she didn't go to ben shapiro and say
hi i work in the same business as you
but i have no idea how to be successful
at it you are much much better at this
and approximately five million times
more successful please teach me your
ways
now if you want to be successful that's
what you do when you're around people
who are more successful than you in the
same field instead she stood off at a
distance
tweeting angrily and demanding that this
man who could teach her so much be
escorted off the premises
and and maybe as i say this i'm kind of
explaining part of the problem there is
no doubt a lot of jealousy at work here
the daily wire is conservative but that
alone is not our our sin right our sin
is that we are conservative
and wildly successful that's why they
can't stand us
in fact they're more than happy
to have conservatives who are in these
same spaces but are not successful
that's good
but to be successful in their space and
to be more successful than them that's
that's just not that's unthinkable
and yet as ridiculous as all this is
we cannot fail to notice the more
serious
implications
so
it's bad enough when a conservative is
judged dangerous or harmful for the
opinions that he's expressing
it's bad enough when
our ideas
are treated like chemical weapons
what happened yesterday represents an
escalation beyond all of that
it's not simply ben's opinions that are
dangerous now it is his presence his
existence in physical space is harmful
and painful
now i don't think i need to spell out
why this is
you know
why this is a problem
when it's determined that a
conservative's mere presence
can cause harm
the stage has been set for some rather
dark and terrible things
and if i do need to spell it out then i
will say that labeling the physical
presence of a group of people harmful
is pre-genocide talk
it is quite literally a justification
for rounding people up and throwing them
in prisons or mass graves
and if it was just some group of fragile
podcasters talking this way it'd be
nothing to worry about but the problem
is that this is increasingly the
language adopted by all of the most
powerful institutions in america
that those with wrong ideas are not just
wrong
uh they're dangerous they're terrorists
and they have to be dealt with
accordingly you know we've been
following the dramatic story of walrus
gate and i told you yesterday that this
scandal goes right to the top um and
bench shapiro's already getting a lot of
heat
and i don't mean to add to it but but i
am going to add to it
because his producer sent me this this
is a totally real i guess he was asked
about at some point about the giant
walrus and um
this is a totally real hot mic moment
that was sent to me
i can't tell you who who i can't tell
you who my source is
but here it is
hey man do you know where matt flores is
no
he's getting pretty upset about it
something get back to work
that hurts i
i do i understand i actually understand
i take back everything i said
at the beginning of the show the whole
monologue i retracted
i totally understand how the people at
the podcast convention felt
it's painful
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there